de obras de arte entre esculturas
pinturas e instalaciones eso es la fiac
la feria internacional de arte
contemporáneo que abrió sus puertas aquí
en parís es una cita que se realiza
anualmente desde
1974 sin embargo el año pasado no pudo
realizarse por cuenta del coi de 19
hablamos con algunos galeristas que nos
contaron que era lo que más esperaban de
esta edición mucho más que hacer buenos
negocios como se ve y comenzar con la
sonrisa y energía muchos ánimos y de
verdad humanamente creo que es muy
importante volver a vernos hablarnos
además de hacer negocios el lado humano
es fundamental para el placer de vivir
viva
es mucho más que un lugar de negocios de
feria es en verdad un lugar de encuentro
amistoso profesional artístico hay
muchos artistas que vienen para ver las
nuevas tendencias encontrarse con amigos
entonces para nosotros este es sobre
todo el año del reencuentro
en los últimos años la fia que ha
tratado de llegar a un público mucho más
amplio llevando el arte al aire libre la
obra que siempre se espera más es la que
adorna la plaza de fondo mch y donde me
encuentro en este año el turno es para
flying dragon esta especie de libélula
gigante que adorna esta plaza es de
alexander calder una obra que el maestro
estadounidense realizó en 1975
justamente un año antes de su muerte la
fia que estará abierta hasta el próximo
domingo pero en cambio este dragón de
rojo fuego sí estará aquí hasta enero
del próximo año